The Joe Rogan Experience when you first
started doing these videos did you have
to figure out a way to balance your own
mental health with interviewing these
people because I gotta tell you like I
watched a bunch of videos today in the
gym while I was working on I felt like
[ __ ] and I always feel good after I work
I know it affects people in different
ways some people make oh my God my
problems are not some so bad my life is
pretty great I've heard that many times
I've heard that more often but I get
what you're saying because like I'm
immersed in it yeah what you see on my
YouTube channel is 1200 maybe 1300
videos I've done over five thousand
because not everything I shoot like with
you you're shooting
you're doing interviews with uh Elon
Musk and Dave Chappelle and
you know huberman and they're great you
know they're going to great they're big
you don't need to do eight or ten in a
day like I do right like I'll do six
seven eight nine ten in a day
hoping to get one or two but even the
ones that you have where the people can
barely communicate they they're almost
more disturbing like I watched a couple
today of homeless people yeah where you
know there was this one woman she was
missing one of her toes and you know
that woman and she's just the movement
and the the mental health
the the obvious signs that she's very
troubled and probably on some drugs and
it's just yeah
if you have children I do I have two
daughters 19 and 22. yeah so that to me
was like the hearing the stories of how
they were all abused sexually and
physically when they're children and
and seeing what it leads to right so I'm
aware that these things go on yeah I've
been down on Skid Row for
12 years now maybe 13 years and so I
know what you live down there no no no
no I I live in Pacific Palisades which
is like the exact opposite yes I live in
Bel Air basically but then I go down to
the worst I go from the worst part of
town to the best part of town yeah it's
a big it's a drastic change from yeah
from one to the other
um but
even when I was doing this before I
started soft white underbelly I was
aware that this sh this crap is going on
to these people when they were kids yeah
and when I decided you know I gave up
advertising I want to do something that
was meaningful to me
I looked around like that's a problem
that needs to be addressed
and you know people say oh your work's
exploitive you're exploiting these poor
drug addicts like
I understand there's an exploitative
element to to it all photography has
that you know element to it but
let's say I never did these videos let's
say we just pretend they pretend these
problems don't exist
it's all going to continue and
Caroline's kids are going to get
molested by the babysitter or by the
uncle or by whoever it's going to repeat
the pattern over and over and over so I
figured by putting out these
you know it's disguised as entertainment
but what it really is is if you watched
a dozen of them you're going to learn
like [ __ ] we need to protect our kids we
need to watch our kids we need to
you know how many fathers were absent in
these kids lives that I do like
like one percent of them had fathers
that were in their lives right
like where are the dads what are they
doing that's so important that they
can't raise their own kid
well they're probably [ __ ] up too
which is well that's where it goes it's
a never-ending side it's generation it's
cycle after cycle have you interviewed
anyone and then come back years later
and they straighten their life out yeah
yeah that's happened yeah
I've done five thousand right and it's
literally like
four
that I know of
and what has that been like like can you
give me and yeah I mean they um
and and even though they've done it
doesn't mean they didn't break down and
relapse tomorrow you know today right
that happens all the time yeah just as
they got clean doesn't mean they're
going to stay clean but
um
the ones that I believe in the most
because some people told me they were
clean but I I don't I don't buy it
but the ones that I know are clean
they just they just did it by themselves
they just hold themselves up and they
figured out a way to wean themselves and
change their routine and change their
environment and eventually broke through
but I think you need that self-worth
like you you and I have the self-worth
to go you know I deserve better I
deserve to drive a nice car I deserve to
live in a great house in a great City
and have a great job and I deserve all
these things and have a great woman in
my life and all these things
if you have the self-worth you're going
to accept and build those things in your
life
these people especially the ones on Skid
Row the drug addicts their self-worth is
broken it's broken
and they don't believe they deserve
anything better than to live in a
cardboard box or a tent on the sidewalk
in the rain in the winter
and they're doing the drug just to
escape the pain of what happened to them
when they were seven years old that
their dad or uncle or
oh brother or whoever yeah and it's like
you you can't fix a childhood
how do you fix a childhood when you see
a place like skid row and you see all
these people that you've interviewed
do you try to formulate some way that
these people can be helped like that we
can diminish this problem you know when
I first really got serious like three
and a half years ago was when I started
really just I was down there every day
doing eight eight interviews a day
I would uh
see somebody who's like oh my God your
life would be great if you just got
clean I was naive I was naive
and uh
I started helping them and like we're
going to get you to rehab and you know I
spent so much money like I've wasted so
much money
my own hearted money I just like put
towards somebody that had no intention
of really
ever doing anything
well it seems like it has to come from
the individual it can it has to from
that's what I've learned you can't help
people by saying hey no no I do this no
I see all these comments on my videos
Mark you didn't help this person
I I can't change their self-worth you'd
have to be with them 24 hours you have
to be with them 24 hours a day you'd
have to be spending easy
150 000
at least a year to house them to feed
them to transport them to get them
therapy to you know all the drugs all
that mental health drugs all the
everything they're going to need doctors
all that stuff it's a lot of money for
one person and it may not we may not
even work right so I'm I got two kids of
my own I got my own life I got bills on
my own I got I'm doing a YouTube channel
and I'm shooting eight videos a day
like when am I gonna sit there and take
somebody under my wing and save them
right
you know these people are on their
phones on their sofa
texting you know uh leave me a comment
saying Mark you didn't help this person
I'm the busiest person I know I'm a I
haven't taken a day off in over three
years
Christmas birthday everything I work
every single day
either shooting or editing and uh
and these people are sitting on their
phones telling me what to do they they
can't get off their ass and maybe you
know clear out their bank account to
save somebody
but even that probably wouldn't do it
and still wouldn't work what do you
think could be done
well I mean it's it's a it's such a
complicated problem you look at homeless
you have the homelessness problem you
have it a little bit here in Austin but
in La it's really bad let's explain Skid
Row to people Skid Row is a
neighborhood it's probably
I don't know how many square blocks but
maybe it's
it goes from like roughly because it
spreads out a lot and it's spread out
since I've been there but let's call it
like from fourth or fifth Street to 8th
Street
this is just east of downtown L.A and
downtown L.A is cool it's nice but just
just east of downtown I know I know I
know but but it looks like Austin I
wouldn't recommend people visit no no
you wouldn't find out a place no you
wouldn't go to go to L.A you don't go
every other town you go downtown right
every every other I'm from Chicago every
year are you going to say Chicago you go
to visit Chicago you spend the whole
time downtown yeah in L.A you should not
go downtown yeah that's what I'm saying
that's exactly right
um but Skid Row is this neighborhood
just east of downtown
that is the
yeah Jamie's got um an image of it yeah
there it is let's let's find some photos
of it because it's it's kind of an
enormous swath of land that's been
completely abandoned it seems like but
like like this girl smoking right here
yeah that goes on every block the cops
Will Roll by
nobody's stopping her she's smoking meth
she's smoking uh something meth or crack
or whatever
let's find a video of it so you can see
this this scale of it because it's
pretty it's pretty intense when you see
people uh like I found out about Skid
Row when we were filming Fear Factor
downtown we filmed a lot of episodes of
Fear Factor downtown and
um I just and this was
early 2000s and it was uh nothing like
it is now I'm sure now it's quite a bit
more but even back then it was like how
is this one area isolated like how is
this one area just filled with homeless
people and drug addicts and criminals
and I really didn't know until I watched
this Netflix series on the Jerome hotel
and it was about that woman who died in
a water tank do you you wear that story
I don't but I've heard everything it's a
woman who got off her meds and it was
um there was a video of her in an
elevator and it looked like someone was
following her and she was like looking
out of the elevator and then the woman
turned up missing and her family went to
look for and what it turned out was uh
she that's a crime scene event this I'm
sorry did I say the Jerome where's the
Jerome is that down there too it's an
idea I don't know
Cecil's notorious the sea salt that's
the one I met the Cecil is a hotel I've
heard so many stories my my favorite or
the most horrifying is so many people
used to get thrown off the roof of the
Cecil hotel that the little chicken
restaurant on the corner used to have a
jar
where you could put your money in and
place bets on what floor the person
would be
have have been pushed out of Jesus
Christ whether it's the roof the 13th
floor how many
oh I like I've heard the like hundreds I
think maybe I'm exact you know stories
get exaggerated over the years but so
this documentary was about this woman
and she had gotten off her medication
and at first it was like a crime murder
mystery and then as it goes on you
realize oh no this lady had just escaped
from her family and got off her meds and
she was paranoid schizophrenic and it's
always none of these stories are as
simple as oh I just got shot or I just
got stabbed yeah there's mental health
that's mixed in I mean the whole problem
like
you asked me what the problem is with
all this so you see homelessness you see
all these homeless people on the street
in LA or in San Francisco or Seattle or
Portland OR Vancouver or you see it in a
lot of cities
it's really bad in L.A in San Francisco
and the West Coast for some reason has a
ton of it
so oh you just like what Ellie's doing
you put them up in housing problem
solved right and we're done
not really no because you peel back the
layer the first the top layer of that
the homeless underneath the homelessness
is uh drug addiction
pretty much 100 across the board none of
these home none of these people are down
and out and just like oh my God I'm
homeless that doesn't happen they're
they're all drug addicts and even when
they tell you they're clean they're
still lying
so you peel back the drug addiction
layer and what are you going to do get
them put them all in rehab which is
going to be tremendously expensive it's
not going to work all the time but
that would be part of the solution but
it's not going to be the solution
so you peel back the layer of drug
addiction you've got Mental Health
they all have mental health issues
and you can't just magically fix their
mental health you know the damage was
done when they were little kids
when they were five six seven eight
years old
with with whether it's neglect or
abuse you know physical abuse sexual
abuse whatever
just terrible parenting yeah terrible
role models terrible and they don't
learn this you know let's say you've
fixed let's say you got them off the
streets let's say you
um
fix the drug addiction
you get them therapy for years and you
fix the mental health issue somewhat but
they still don't know how to
do all the things that we all know how
to do
like
build trust in others
gain the trust of others
how to handle money
to delay gratification delay
gratification they don't they have no
concept of that everything is just like
how do I make a quick Buck right now
yeah that's the only thing they know if
you know if they have a job interview on
Monday
like if I had something like that or a
meeting to go to I would know how to
show up I'm going to kick ass on Monday
these people don't know how to do
anything like that
they might they probably won't even show
up
they don't know how to be on time they
don't know how to do anything in order
to like Advance their
their lives I think it's it boils down
to their
self-worth is so broken that they don't
believe they deserve anything better
yeah so if you don't believe you deserve
anything better you could be handed a
million dollars here's a winning lottery
ticket go cash it in if you've got a
million dollars
they're going to [ __ ] it up as fast as
you can see it
you know as fast as you can imagine